Mark 11 Matthew 21 Jesus cursed the Fig
Tree but it wasn't season for figs
that's in Mark 11 let me get you the
article and I'll explain it guys here it
is the article please save it click on
it save it why did Jesus cursed the Fig
Tree when it wasn't season for figs here
you go brother you got the
article I just sent it to you in the
comment section you got
it I think I got like I think I got the
I gave you all
no but you go down I just posted it
there it's right there man you don't get
it okay you say it oh wait you'll say it
no I don't see oh you know why because
it didn't go through I gave you guys the
wrong link I'm sorry because remember
I'm mentally challenged
here hey brother here's the argument I
gave you the link just save them I'm
gonna explain the answer are you ready
you guys
ready what's the answer notice it's
around Passover week and Passover takes
place in spring right
and spring is usually when you get the
first harvest
correct yes okay pay attention to the
argument guys pay attention to the
objection Jesus went looking for figs
and he found no figs and he cursed the
tree and the Fig Tree withered even
though it wasn't seasoned for figs
that's what Mark says why did Jesus
curse a fig tree expecting to find figs
when it wasn't season for figs
you understand the objection in the
article I gave you anyone who knows
Israel geography if you are fam familiar
with the geography of Israel and
Jerusalem you will know that right
before fig
season a fig tree will have small knobs
called t t the t is edible you can eat
it the t is an indic
this tree is good and will produce fruit
figs if there are no T that means this
fig tree is no good and it's withered
that means Jesus was looking for T he
was looking for these knobs to eat when
he saw none that was an indication that
the Fig Tree was Barren and good for
nothing but
destruction you with me there did you
get it or no yeah okay I'm still I'm
still like um trying to
comprehend when you approach a fig tree
right around fix season because this is
right around fix season what you expect
to find on a fig tree is things called
knob it's called a knob the word is
Tu those knobs are edible you can eat
them if you find knobs on the fig tree
that's an indication
that this fig tree is good and it's
going to produce
figs if there are no knobs no Tu that
means it's Barren it's no good so what
Jesus would be looking for is
what he's looking for the the the the TU
he found
none which means it had no figs to Bear
which means it's Barren good for nothing
but
destruction okay now it makes sense yeah
okay but now what did the Fig
represent it wasn't simply he was hungry
and there were no knobs and no talk
showing it's Barren in the article I
show you that Israel is likened to a fig
tree that's spoiled so this is a played
out parable in which by cursing the Fig
Tree the Fig Tree is a picture of Israel
Jesus has come to Jerusalem
looking for Spiritual fruit he finds
none because Israel is spoiled and
rotten and it's good for nothing but
destruction which is why he then
destroys the city and the Temple 40
years
later okay making
sense yeah yeah let me prove to you
Israel is symbolized by the Fig Tree are
you ready yes Luke 13 6-9 first and last
Luke 13
6-9 6 yeah I'm going to read it when he
posts it Luke 1369 it's all my article
he also spoke a parable a certain man
had a fiig tree planted in his Vineyard
and he came seeking fruit on it and
found none he came doing
what he came seeking fruit on it and
found none so what did he do
brother man had a fig tree planted in
his vineard and he came and sought fruit
thereon and found
none okay and then he goes then then
said he unto the the desert the dresser
of his Vineyard behold these three years
I come seeking fruit on this fig tree
and find none cut it down why cth it the
ground and he answered said unto him
Lord let it alone this year also till I
shall dig about it and dun in and dug it
and if it bear fruit well and if not
then after that thou shalt cut it down
okay Israel's liken to a fig tree right
yes and when Jesus came looking for figs
he found no figs right yes and for three
years he found no figs on the fig tree
called Israel right yes and he said you
know what cut it down however the the
dresser the one who who was nurturing
and nourishing the fig tree with the
hopes that it would produce fix says
give it one more year and if not then
burn it down so you understand now why
he went to a fiig tree found none and he
cursed it because the Fi Tree that
actual tree represented Israel that
Jesus keeps coming to Jerusalem looking
for fruit he finds nothing but spoiled
rotten fruit and therefore Israel left
leaves him no choice but now to destroy
it like he destroyed that fig tree and
when did he destroy it 40 years 40 years
later when he destroyed Jerusalem and
the temple because Israel was
spiritually dead Barren producing rotten
fruit
okay now now I like this this is I I get
I get it now I really
do okay so you got it now brother yes I
did thank you so much okay so you
understand first of all why did he curse
an actual fig tree because he was
looking for knobs T the T would a sign
that this fig tree is fruitful right yes
finding none what did that
mean it it wasn't fruitful so it's good
for nothing but to be destroyed right
yeah pretty much but in destroying that
physical fig tree it was a sign of
Jerusalem because notice when this is
taking place when he's going into the
temple he enters the temple and he
cleans it from its evil and impurity so
instead of finding spiritual fruit in
the temple he finds spiritual corruption
and evil and he's disgusted so that act
is a sign your days are numbered
Jerusalem because you are like that fig
tree cursed rotten no good comes out of
you leaving me no choice but to destroy
you like I destroyed that fig tree
that's the point